in one provincial capital after another
the taliban are running up their colours
and taking control
the speed of their advance has surprised
almost everyone they're on a roll and
heading for kabul say analysts
they're very clear that they've won this
war and they're very pumped up they're
energized you know so for them there's
no stopping and that means taking kabul
yeah i mean the whole country absolutely
this is afghanistan four months ago as a
withdrawal began the country's provinces
looked like this with most of the
territory in grey showing areas being
fought over look at it today most of the
country is under taliban control in
territory march red and now the capital
kabul is looking increasingly isolated
with the taliban surrounding it more and
more taking ghazni city in the east
sarah poole in the north and farah and
zarage to the west
and they've turned on other targets like
kandahar the country's second largest
city and their spiritual birthplace and
lashkargar capital of helmand where many
british soldiers died fighting to keep
the province from taliban control
[Music]
the taliban have an effective strategy
and are fighting and increasingly
demoralized enemy
[Applause]
the hasty american withdrawal is working
in their favor and they have momentum on
their side
the afghan people are
[Music]
less optimistic than they were they were
about the government's ability to
withstand the taliban and that could
lead to people switching sides
[Music]
in one sense that could
reach a tipping point very soon
u.s airstrikes are less and less
effective the more the taliban are
enmeshed in urban areas military options
are limited so what about diplomacy can
negotiations slow them down at the
moment war is the most important part of
politics
and it's it's the developments on the
battlefield over the next few weeks or
months
that that are going to shape the
politics and shape the diplomacy
if the taliban can be fought to a
stalemate negotiations might have a
chance of brokering a power sharing deal
but for now at least on the ground in
afghanistan that isn't looking likely
dominick waghorn sky news